identifica los siguientes valores en una
recta numérica y tenemos estos valores
si ustedes se dan cuenta tenemos aquí el
símbolo de valor absoluto pero vamos a
recordar que es el valor absoluto porque
de qué manera lo vamos a lograr si no
sabemos que es el valor absoluto vamos a
poner aquí valor
su luto y hay dos formas de saber el
valor absoluto de estos números la
primera es pensar qué tan lejos están
del cero vamos a ver si tenemos una
recta numérica
pensemos que este
el 0
buscaremos entonces el valor de menos 3
primero vamos a hacer algo vamos a
colocar el número que está dentro del
símbolo del valor absoluto y después
haremos una recta numérica con el valor
absoluto que esta primera recta
veamos tiene un -3 coloquemos menos 1 -
2 - 3
este -3 se colocaría aquí menos 3
y nuestro valor absoluto conceptualmente
es saber qué tan lejano se encuentra del
así es que menos 3 se encuentra a 1 2 3
del 092 que menos 3
tendrá un valor absoluto de 3 porque
porque está a tres lugares de distancia
del 0 1 2 3 pero esta es la parte
conceptual la parte más sencilla y si lo
quieren ver en términos super fáciles es
si yo tengo un número negativo su valor
absoluto será ese mismo número pero en
positivo o si ya lo tenemos en positivo
no se iguala a sí mismo
vamos a colocar entonces la recta
numérica esta será nuestra recta
numérica de las respuestas
si estamos hablando que todos los
valores absolutos serán positivos esta
recta empezará en cero
bueno aquí colocaremos menos 1 1 2 3 4 5
6 pero muy apretado vamos a hacerlo más
separado
7 yo creo que con eso tenemos espacio
entonces marquemos vamos a volver a
poner en este color
las respuestas vamos a identificar
entonces el valor absoluto de menos 3
hemos quedado que es 3 y colocaremos el
punto aquí lo identificaremos aquí
vamos a marcar el 0 para que nos demos
cuenta que estamos en relación al 0
vámonos con el siguiente número
valor absoluto de 7 si lo colocamos aquí
tendríamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 qué tan lejos
se encuentra del 0 pues 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
entre el 0 17 hay 7 así es que el valor
absoluto de 7 será igual a 7 y lo
ubicamos en nuestra recta numérica de
respuesta 7 ahora vamos a hacer el que
sigue
8 - 12 primero tenemos que identificar
cuánto es 8 menos 12
tendremos entonces qué
8 - 12 será igual a valor absoluto de
menos 4 porque porque sea 8 le quitó 8
quedó en cero y nos vamos todavía hacia
el menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 dado que le
estamos quitando 12 ahora el menos 4 si
lo ubicamos en nuestra tabla de lejanía
contra el 0 tendremos aquí un -4 y para
saber el valor absoluto nos
preguntaremos qué tan lejanos estamos
del 0 pues muy fácil estamos a 1 2 3 4
valor absoluto de menos 4 es igual a 4 y
lo identificamos en nuestra recta
numérica
de respuesta uno más este y lo haremos
con anaranjado cuál es el valor absoluto
de cero
pues el 0 está a 0 de cero es decir
simplemente colocaremos
el 0 perfectamente ubicado aquí dado que
está a nada del 0 es el mismo 0
y finalmente vamos a hacer uno más vamos
a agarrar un color brillante
7 - 2 cuál es el valor absoluto de 72
primero vamos a identificar cuánto es 7
menos 2 y 7 menos 2 es igual a 5 los
dejamos dentro del símbolo de valor
absoluto para que así podamos pasar el
mismo resultado
ahora identifiquemos dónde está el 5 1 2
3 4 5 y el 5 está aquí qué tan lejano
está del 0 vamos a sacar el valor
absoluto está a 1 2 3 4 5
respuesta es igual a 5
solo para ser más claros y hacer un
resumen breve el valor absoluto desde el
concepto es saber qué tan lejano es ese
número del 0 o en términos mucho más
prácticos si es negativo se vuelve
positivo es exactamente el mismo número
pero en positivo o si es positivo
simplemente se iguala a sí mismo y listo
con eso tenemos nuestra respuesta y la
resaltará aquí
fácil no nos vemos en otro vídeo